as we saw in the last video in 1942 we
start to see the tide turn in the
pacific just as a reminder in december
of 1941 you have the japanese attack of
pearl harbor which brings the united
states into world war ii and as we get
into 1942 you have the doolittle raid on
the mainland of japan which is a
psychological victory for america and
the allies then you have the battle of
coral sea and then midway midway in
particular was a huge actually i
shouldn't put red there i should just
leave it blue it was a huge success
for the american for the american navy
followed by guadalcanal where the u.s is
actually after which is able to go on
the offensive against the japanese so we
see a significant turning of the tide in
1942 in the pacific and it also turns
out to be the case in europe that we see
a turning of the tide in 1942.
just as guadalcanal is occurring you
might remember that in 1941
hitler and the nazis decided they want
to attack the soviet union
probably not a good idea they're going
to stretch themselves thin but they do
so
they do so
anyway they have the siege of leningrad
starts in starts in 1941 and then in
1942 by august they're able to reach
stalingrad which is
right
about here and stalingrad it's now
called vogelgrad it's right about there
if the map extended over there
this is a major i guess you could say
battle or even series of battles in
world war ii movies are made about
stalingrad incredibly bloody incredibly
uh kind of this you know really i mean
you know if you look at pictures of the
city of stalingrad after after the siege
after after it's after the the battle's
there the the city was is essentially in
ruins but stalingrad the the the the
battle or the battles you should say
it's stalingrad
they start in august of 1942 and they
continue for several months going up to
february of 1943 but this marks the
turning point for hitler he's getting
bogged down in leningrad getting bogged
down in stalingrad eventually gets
defeated in stalingrad in early 1943 and
his armies are really really really
spread thin so this is stalingrad is a
is a hugely
hugely important
important event or series of events in
world war ii and let's just be clear
where we are right now stalingrad
commences in august of 19
august of 1942 and just to kind of frame
it in your mind
relative to the pacific theater this is
right around you know plus or minus a
few weeks of when guadalcanal was going
on conflict between the japanese and the
american navies so you have you have the
you have this incredibly bloody battle
or series of battles at stalingrad
then in october we've been talking about
this back and forth in north africa and
some people say well you know why is you
know why are they even worried about
north africa and i should have mentioned
this earlier but we have to remember
that there's something somewhat
strategic here called the suez canal why
is the suez canal strategic well it
connects the mediterranean with the red
sea and then eventually the indian ocean
so that you don't have to go all the way
around africa to go from europe to the
indian ocean so it's an incred
incredibly strategic
i guess passage or or a way to travel by
sea between well i guess for the for the
world but especially between europe and
between asia and so you can imagine the
british were very keen on protecting the
suez canal and the axis would have loved
to get control of the suez canal let me
write this here this right over here is
the suez
suez
canal
and as we go into october if we go into
october so this is stalingrad commences
right over here and then as we go into
october you have the british are able to
defeat the axis or start to defeat the
axis and then push them back and this
eventually leads to the british being
able to go all the way to tunisia so
this is kind of the final back and forth
blow that kind of starts to secure
victory for the allies in north africa
and at the same time that this is
commencing in october at the same time
that this is commencing in october you
have other allied forces starting to
arrive in mara in morocco and algeria
forces from the u.s are arriving in
are arriving in
morocco and forces from the uk from
great britain are arriving in are
arriving in algeria so this is going to
give the allies control of north africa
from which they can now mount assaults
onto
onto the european mainland which we will
see in the next series of videos so
definitely the tide is turning and the
allies are starting to be able to go on
the offensive both in the pacific and in
the european theater